[Music]
foreign
the only thing I have from the dad I
never knew is half of a locker we must
be brothers that's just brothers Trevor
twins wow we're twins we're
identical twins if mom and dad got
married again then we'd have a real
family what if we trick them into
getting back together
what are you doing here the twins
the service is my Palace built they
break my brick so get in the line
dropping your knees and suck my
dick
should I open another bottle I know it's
our second but we're not Baptist should
we drown them in the bathtub in an
old-fashioned way y'all up
I'm gay queer is a three dollar bill in
just as thin who likes the hand
job and I owe
God
[Applause]
[Music]
wow a lady boss I guess it really is the
year that it is
I'm so sorry did you say sewer boys
disgusting they're not disgusting
they're gay culture
oh
[Music]
[Applause]